[Music]
good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight how do you know if you're living
in a free society here's a quick test
are you allowed to say obviously true
things in public or are you forced to
lie as George Orwell put it in 1984
freedom is the freedom to say that two
plus two make four if that is granted
all else follows but what if that
freedom isn't granted what if you're
required to repeat things you know
aren't true what if everyone who hears
you knows perfectly well that you're
lying but can't say so out loud what if
everyone is required instead to not
along and mock sincerity as if it's all
completely real that's what a pep rally
in a police state looks like thanks to
the Dear Leader for a bountiful potato
harvest they chant even as they starve
to death you get the same feeling as you
watch the current race for the
Democratic nomination Pete Budaj edge is
in that race a few years ago back when
he was best known for being mayor of
South Bend Indiana Budaj edge made the
point that all lives matter he said it
because it's true
all lives do matter no matter what they
look like every life has value period
that's the message of Christianity and
of the civilization that it spawned in
the West but in the modern Democratic
Party that can no longer be acknowledged
so Buddha jej apologized for his wrong
think 2015 you said that all lives
matters when you spoke about two police
controversies that were happening in
South Bend was that a mistake what I did
not understand at that time was that
that phrase just early into MIT
especially 2015 was coming to be viewed
as
counter slogan two black lives matter
and so this statement that seems very
anodyne and something that is kind of
nobody could be against actually wound
up being used to devalue what the black
lives matter movement was telling us
since learning about how that phrase was
being used to push back on that activism
I stopped using it I'm sorry I said all
lives matter I won't say that again
going forward only some lives will
matter whatever lives the party deems
meaningful I am Penton and I stand
corrected the crowd dotted gravely we
are pleased to see your turn of heart
comrade police Boone a judge managed to
preserve some dignity as he went through
the motions of his ritual apology beta
were Roark who is 46 years old and still
skateboards has no dignity when asked
about a harmless joke he once told about
his wife staying home to raise the kids
a rock fell apart completely
he grovelled and whimpered and abased
himself he even expanded the
self-criticism and apologized for how he
was born constructive criticism it is
already made me a better candidate not
only will I not say that
but but I'll be much more thoughtful
going forward in the way that I talked
about our marriage and also the way in
which I acknowledged the truth of the
criticism that I have enjoyed white
privilege absolutely undeniable this is
what Maoist tribunals look like during
the Cultural Revolution
by summer you can picture bata wearing a
paper dunce cap with white privilege
scrawled across it in red letters as a
warning to other would-be
counter-revolutionaries pretty much
everyone running for president as a
Democrat this year has had to face
inquisitions like this they write their
confessions of guilt bowing before their
accusers on social media and begging for
forgiveness Kirsten Gillibrand read her
confession on live television years ago
when she was running for a different
office Gillibrand once expressed
sympathy for the idea of a border
looking back she is deeply ashamed she
could hardly believe she ever thought
something so immoral he essentially said
that you were embarrassed about your
previous position on immigration tell me
about that
well I don't think it was driven from my
heart I was callous to the suffering of
families who want to be with their loved
ones people who want to be reunited with
their families and I recognize as we all
do that immigration and diversity is our
strength as a country I really regretted
that I didn't look beyond my district
and talk about why this is an important
part of the United States story
diversity is our strength she says I
once was lost but now I'm found
diversity is our strength this is the
new Nicene Creed don't ask what it means
that's not your place just mouthed the
words there's nothing liberal about any
of this obviously it is purely
authoritarian woke fascism power over
ideas in place of thinking obedience in
return for dissent punishment lying as
an official policy and not just
conventional lying the ordinary truth
shading of everyday life but terrifying
full inversion lies the exact opposite
of the truth the kind of lies that
regimes that seek total control must
tell in order to maintain their power
the latest of these lies is that
low-grade Mafia figure al Sharpton is in
fact a legitimate civil rights
leader all of the Democratic candidates
claimed to believe that now this week
they trooped over to his extremely
tax-exempt organization to pretend he's
the new MLK people like Reverend
Sharpton who has never stopped fighting
for social justice well thank you so
much Reverend thank for thank you for
your wisdom and your witness your work
the Reverend Sharpton fighting for
social justice where are these people in
the mid-1990s when al Sharpton was
denouncing a Jewish landlord in Harlem
as a quote white interloper just before
his store was firebombed and eight
people were killed
well bata was still a Manny then
Christian Gillibrand was a lawyer
working for the cigarette companies none
of them were woke yet they are now watch
them clamor for an idea that not 20% of
the American population supports
race-based reparations
[Applause]
yes I firmly support congresswoman
Jackson Lee's bill to create a
commission to study reparations
[Applause]
well it's like an altar call in fact it
is an altar call the modern version but
the bigger question is that will we get
reparations in this country the real
question is do you want to live in a
place where people like the ones you
just saw on the screen have more
political power where humor and dissent
are criminal acts where lying is the
currency of public life where
authorities whose names you don't know
can destroy you for thinking the wrong
things you're familiar with that world
you've seen it before
it's called Twitter imagine if it had
control of the US military